so you love animals so much you name all
of them right any of course yes okay you
have an animal game to have an animal
game we're gonna do I'm gonna do an
animal game I would love to okay can we
go through some of your animal catchers
and maybe the game is you tell us what
their name okay yeah okay this is I
don't think you remember okay love my
life Norman he's been with women for 13
years I love that you picked an old man
a my dog's name is Henry always full old
man named yeah he's the love of my life
okay okay next picture oh that's fine
that's Simon as you can tell the only
travels private hey can someone give me
a cocktail look at my gosh I love okay
next okay that's my new he's a dwarf
rescue goat and his name is tarantula
and don't question it because look at
him he looks just like a tarantula yeah
and I swear he knows his name it's so
weird I mean he looks like a goat but
the coloring is that again yeah yes
obsessed yet that little guy he's
adorable oh that's that's tank I say man
I look at tank he's very proud of Simon
the tank came with my husband so I have
yeah he's that I love that his name is
day I mean would you accept anything
else
oh my god he's so great I love your oh
and that's our supermodel dog that's
blueberry
she's our rescue pit bull that we
rescued this year does she have some uh
what do they call a she has contacts in
her eyes no I forget the name of the dog
it looks Oh mime Reiner Reiner Weimer
Annie she is not but that she's a
because she's like yeah looks just like
okay I was like a Weimer and she is a
very special Thank You Alec love her
Weimaraner
alright well alright I love that you
like
[Music]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this